Wells Fargo just turned cautious on
stocks and their reason has to do with
the anthropic IPO coming up in part as
to why they think there's this extremism
of a lack of liquidity that we're seeing
for hardware stocks or enthusiasm for
the stock market broadly. They think
some of it could be because of the
September before midterms is usually
bearish. afterwards. We, as we've heard
from JP Morgan, tend to see with almost
certainty green markets, which you know,
you never want to be too certain in
markets. But Wells Fargo actually argues
that the anthropic S1 could be one of
the most critical catalysts coming up.
And so what I'd like to do is go through
some of the Barclay's reported unit
economics for anthropic because they'll
give us a little bit of a primer for
what we could expect to see in the
anthropic S1. And it's in my opinion not
just that S1 which is the initial filing
when you want to go public that'll be
important but it's also going to be the
change over time. So really there's a
very simple thing we're looking for.
People are just going to be defining
this in different ways and you'll see
that as we go through the Barclay's
analysis. The way you could analyze this
gets really funky but there's a very
simple motive. Everybody wants to know
how much profit does a company like
Anthropic actually make? Let's get rid
of the, you know, rearranging of numbers
and trying to play games. Let's actually
see the real numbers. But it's not just
going to be the point in time that we
care about. What we're going to care
about is the trajectory. Is this profit
going up? If it's going up, we call
that, you know, X1. Call that X knot
over here. Is are we going up to X1? Are
we going, you know, exponentially up
over here to X2 or are we actually
trending more like to X3, right? And so
that trend that we see over time will
help us see is the capex boom and
artificial intelligence truly
sustainable or are these companies like
Anthropic and OpenAI truly just drunk
sailors blowing money on anything they
can get their hands on to expand the
amount of compute they have so they can
hopefully get a few more subscribers and
uh ultimately uh you know pump their
stock before the eventual bleed out. So
that's the big question here. Apple, for
example, is a massive beneficiary now
apparently of OpenAI buying thousands,
tens of thousands of Mac M5 Ultra
Studios, which is incredible because you
could actually buy this whole set of
hardware for less than what you could
buy an RTX 6000 for, which will cost
you, you know, retail somewhere around
14 to $15,000.
And if you're, you know, able to buy it
wholesale, you're still paying about 11
grand. But you could get a 96GB
VRAMm or unified RAM Apple for
somewhere, you know, these M5s for
somewhere around 8 grand. Whereas even
if you didn't pay wholesale pricing for
that same 96GB,
you know, you're you're paying almost
twice as much money. So
that's one of the reasons Apple
continues to see this pop in markets
right now. And I think it'll continue at
least until we start seeing bearishness
from these AI labs. And that's where the
profitability measures here become
really important. So take a look at
this. You've got over here a primer on
AI lab hyperscaler unit economics. They
basically start by saying it's going to
be hard to compare them because they're
going to present information in a
different way. And they go through this
hypothetical of like let's compare
potential margins for lab A and lab B.
This is anthropic in OpenAI. In my
opinion, I think A is anthropic and and
[clears throat] I kind of think it's
hilarious that they literally now have
to write hypothetical. I wrote this
note. I said they literally now have to
write hypothetical about their research
to [clears throat] avoid pissing off
labs when those labs end up coming to
ask for loans and the banks want to help
them IPO. Keep in mind that's very
profitable for the finance industry is
helping a business IPO because they're
going to take, you know, their six or 7%
commission. They're going to take a
commission on uh putting the loans
together. And these aren't like doing a
mortgage where, you know, somebody's
coming in and getting a $600,000
mortgage and the lender's making one
point which works out to 1%. These
[clears throat] are bankers that are
doing, you know, a $600 million loan and
they're [clears throat] taking points on
that. So now you're talking about
millions of dollars of revenue to the
bottom line. That's why the bankers have
to be really careful about pissing off
the labs. This is why you get like the
Adam Jonas that gets on the knees for
Elon Musk and Morgan Stanley to bow down
to the god because you think the CEO at
Morgan Stanley gives a flying hoot if
SpaceX actually goes up or down. Spoiler
alert, he doesn't. He cares about how
much revenue baby Morgan Stanley's going
to make. And if we can underwrite a
SpaceX IPO or an athropic IPO by being
bullish, hell's yes, we going to be
bullish. Now technically FINRA and the
regulatory agencies will tell you that's
not true Kevin. These departments have
to be firewalled. They have to be
separated
by separate departments, separate
locations within the investment bank.
Underwriting has to be separate from
research. They're not supposed to
connect to each other. But let's be
real, the CEO still pays the checks.
[laughter]
So let's keep going on here. So I just
want to I just want to point that little
bias out. Okay. So um the bias by these
companies is going to be also now this
is from from the actual labs. The lab
bias is going to be to move some of that
training to research and development.
And that's a big line here. So let's
listen to this. Hypothetical frontier
lab A has upwards of 70% of revenue
coming from API and 30% from
subscription. When you hear API, I want
you to think more profit. Business to
business always charges more. Business
to consumer is the broky money. I hate
to say it. Okay, into it. QuickBooks,
how much can they charge for you to do
your tax return? Basically,
[clears throat]
zero. How much can they charge for a
business to run payroll and get all
their data in and then get locked in and
suckered into the subscription?
A lot. Thousands per year. Okay, so this
is very normal. Businesses are really
good at charging other businesses money
and at high premiums because the
switching costs are too interruptive to
a business's top line. So
API very desirable hypothetical Frontier
Lab B has closer to the inverse about
80% coming from subscriptions probably
because GPT assuming B is GPT was sort
of the OG AI model that everybody you
know signed up for the $20 a month for
or whatever. And [clears throat]
this is very sticky to cancel. I
personally try to cancel all my AI
subscriptions every about quarter and
then I only reenable them when I need
them. Uh so to me that's sort of a tool
because like if I signed up for a 100 AI
subscriptions and every quarter I cancel
them all. Great. Then I go into the next
quarter I'm like well which are the five
I actually use. I only resign up for
those. It's great. And usually they give
you like resign up bonuses anyway.
They're like I have a month free just
for coming back. And it's like ah it's
free money to cancel every so often.
That's great. Anyway, it's possible some
of the training costs may be recorded in
R&D for various labs. So, the purpose of
this report, we are showing for the
purposes of this report, we are showing
10% of the training costs in COGS, which
represents the final training for
running an AI model. It's unclear at
this point if the training costs are
going to be allocated uh the way they
indicate or not. So, this is really
important from an investor point of
view. Actually, I think I described this
a little bit better.
We We'll look at this right here. So,
this is going to be in reference to this
page right here. But I I just want you
to fundamentally see why a company is
going to be incentivized to bury things
in a different portion of uh either
their their income statement or
ultimately their balance sheet or
whatever. Okay. So, [clears throat] what
we want to look at when we look at an
income statement and how it'll flow
through a balance sheet,
first of all, when you look at an income
statement and the balance sheet, know
that if you go buy a $15,000
RTX 6000, like I mentioned at the
beginning of the video, that's going to
show up as negative cash and it's going
to show up as plus asset.
uh and only a depreciated portion is
actually going to show up over here as
costs. So when you see AI labs talk
about uh some of their costs of goods
sold, remember that you're generally
only getting a depreciated portion of
that. So if I depreciate this over 15
years like Microsoft does or seven or
eight years like a lot of other firms
do, I'll go with seven years. 15,000
divided by 7. I'm actually only going to
write off in my cost of goods sold about
$2,100 over here. And then I'll decline
the asset value over here. This matters
because the cost of goods sold that
we're seeing are only a fraction of what
was really spent for that hardware. This
is the whole like and we've talked about
it even before Michael Bur, but it's the
whole Michael Bur depreciation argument,
right? So, I want you to keep that in
mind. But another thing that you have to
know about when we talk about these AI
labs in terms of profits has to do with
allocating uh training to research and
development and that's probably the
bigger piece here. Okay. So uh there's
what's called the top line. Uh and this
is going to be your revenue, right? So
you've got revenue coming in, you've got
cost of goods sold, and then you have
what's called gross profit. These
companies are going to want to show the
highest possible gross profit. Under
that you have what's called your
operating expense, also known as opex.
That's where R&D sits. The more you can
bury things that should be costs of
goods sold in R&D, the better you look.
Why? Two reasons. Number one, tax
credits. Research and development gets
you tax credits. Cost of goods sold does
not. So based on the big beautiful bill,
these companies are going to be
incentivized to bury as much of their
training costs to actually have the
frontier language learning models into
R&D purely from a tax point of view. The
second point of view is from a from the
stock angle, investors frequently look
at research and development and think
that is an investment into the future
and for future revenues and future
returns. The problem is when you
actually look at these labs, you have to
remember that the only reason, well
maybe not the only reason, but one of
the leading reasons they're actually
able to generate the revenue that they
do is because they have the leading
model, which in my opinion means in
order to maintain their revenue, they
have to maintain a high level of cost of
goods sold because of massive training
to stay the leading model. You know, if
you have to spend $100 million a year,
just as a quick example, to make $200
million a year, and you have to spend
that hundred every year just to keep
your models ahead in training, then that
should really be a cost of goods sold
for that year. Because as soon as you
don't do that next year, then your
revenue goes down because you're no
longer the leading model. That's a cost
of goods sold. But the labs are probably
going to tell you, "No, man, it's
research and development. Only 10% is
actually cost of goods sold." It's going
to make it look like these companies
actually have a much larger gross profit
than they do. It's designed,
in my opinion, for tax efficiency, but
also intentionally to mislead how these
labs work. Anthropic and OpenAI, if they
were not the leading labs, in my
opinion, would not have the revenue that
they do. Hence, I believe there's going
to be a big misleading going on here.
This is what Barclay's estimates.
Barclays, you can see it right here.
They indicate that right here, this
section, AI paid inference profit. Okay,
this section right here is what they
argue is the gross profit from
inference. They think Anthropic is going
to show a hundred approximately uh
billion dollars of revenue. Uh OpenAI,
well, I think they might just be showing
this on a $100 scale, not necessarily
billions of dollars, but let's just call
let's just assume it's billions of
dollars, right? So $100 billion over
here, $102 billion over here. From a
gross profit point of view, they're
trying to argue that Anthropic is going
to be at about a 65% gross profit margin
and opening eye 48%.
Now, if you then come in and take out
some training, see how they're only
taking out 10 right here, 10% of
training. Now, you could argue that they
have a 55 to 38% gross profit. And then
look what they're literally doing right
here. R&D training costs 70 and 96.
Notice how they've literally and
intentionally not given you a net
margin. They're literally saying, "Oh
yeah, look, these companies are
profitable. Look at this shiny toy right
here. See, look, 65% margin after
training. Wow, still 55% margin." And
then look what they do. They hide right
here in R&D training cost the fact that
70 or 96 which is literally greater than
the AI lab gross profit. The R&D
training costs alone literally leads to
a net loss of 15 billion and 58 billion.
Now one of the reasons there's such a
large difference in these losses
projected right here is basically API.
API makes up almost all of the
difference. There's a $35 billion spread
between these two numbers. If I add API
back in, you actually led to lead to
losses of about 15 billion and 23
billion. It shows you that API is
projected to be the most profitable
portion of these labs. That's selling to
other businesses for coding or whatever.
It's basically how do we integrate this
LLM into your own corporate chatbot, the
Chipotle chatbot, you know, the
Palunteer services, whatever. These are
all API polls of these models.
Great. So, uh they believe that right
here AI lab unit economics have improved
greatly in 2026 because these lab
products are now becoming must buys.
There's a problem with this because in
my opinion we had this massive boom in
the first quarter of uh 2026
and that was the claude code claude
co-work moment that was a fantastic
moment for accelerating agentic AI and
coding artificial intelligence and it
really came because we broke through the
memory wall essentially we went from hey
we are memory starved we can't actually
upload large documents without models
hallucinating
uh because we don't have the memory to
wow we all of a sudden have much more
headroom on memory and because we have
more headroom on memory we're able to uh
contextualize
uh larger code bases medium-sized code
bases largesiz code bases without
hallucinating okay that led to a massive
breakthrough part of it was because the
models got a little bit better but I
actually argue most of it was because we
got past a memory wall. Uh, and that has
led to obviously such a shortage in
memory and and why memory has gotten so
important. But that's kind of an
artificial boost if you think about it.
Like if these models got better because
we just got more access to headroom on a
chip, more memory basically, then the
models didn't actually have to get
better. They just had to have more
context, more KV cache.
And that doesn't actually mean the model
became better. It just means the result
became better. But the result didn't
come become better because the labs got
better. The result got better because
the memory wall went away to some
extent. We still have a memory wall for
for even larger purposes and there's
obviously shortage of memory now. And
I'm not trying to say that the models
didn't get better. They did get better.
But I think the majority of that Q1 gain
came from that explosion in context and
cash available. To me, that's a problem
because it means you're IPOing on the
back of the largest exponential
inflection. And that's actually why I
was reaching for the whiteboard over
here because I want you to think about
it this way. If these labs, you know,
had their boom uh in 2023, you had this
sort of exponential growth. You probably
honestly started scurving out in like 24
25. Anthropic came on the scene uh you
know sort of before this sort of in this
range over here and really what you
happen or had happened in Q1 in my
opinion is you didn't have a return to
exponential growth I think you had a
step change all right so you kind of
stepped up and kept the growth going
over here they are in my humble opinion
taking advantage of that step change to
go, you know what? Let's IPO and show
everybody all that growth because it's
going to imply exponential when it was
really a step change in memory.
Maybe I'm jaded. Call me jaded. But uh
let's keep looking at some of this
commentary here from Barlay. So
they think that Frontier Labs A and B
may have increased paid inference
margins to upwards of 50 to 65%. Again,
they are hiding all of the R&D trading
costs over here, which which I think is
borderline criminal. But remember, I
purposefully started off with the basis
of these people are kind of trying to
mislead you because, you know, they want
the labs to use them for their their
IPO. It's jaded. Call me jaded. You
should you should say Kevin, this this
Kevin guy is way too jaded for me. I'm
going to go listen to a blind bull.
Fine. I accept. So what do we have here?
Based on the model efficiencies and
pricing power. Well, uh oh sorry those
are my notes. Hold on. What do we have
here? So this is what am I saying? I
forgot what I wrote down here. Based on
model efficiencies and pricing power,
we'll see how long that lasts. Okay,
this is what I just described on the
whiteboard. Basically, in other words,
the growth on the left side, we have
2025. On the right side, we have 2026.
And the idea is that you know margins
were able to get a lot better because
their compute costs went down. See
inference costs went down from 79 and 61
to 30 and 30. Part of this reason is
because there has been an increase in
efficiency of providing tokens which is
very useful for the labs. open weight
and Chinese models are obviously going
to be essentially perfect competition
nearly perfect competition I would argue
for compressing how much money these
these labs can actually make. But in the
near term while people are still using
open AI entropic
they can route your queries to more
efficient token models uh unless you're
willing to pay for the bleeding edge you
know fable max or whatever uh and and
capture more of the profit. I don't
think it's unusual
for why it's so obscure at Google, for
example, to figure out which model
should I use. Should I use 3.1 Pro?
Should I use 3.6 Flash? Should I use 3.6
Thinking?
The real intention there is to
purposefully obscure which one you
should use so they can really route you
to the cheapest one and still serve you
while making you feel like you made a
choice. [laughter] Right? That's my
belief and it makes sense because it
really affects their bottom line because
if they could route you through a much
cheaper model and it's been obscured
what model you're actually using, then
they can win. Okay, so what do we have
over here? We conclude that around $35
to $40 of every $100 in AI lab revenue
flows to the hyperscalers. So this is
the current argument that hyperscalers
also make a lot of money uh out of this
lab spend and that there's an
opportunity for those but that that
could fade. I think they actually talk
about specifically which ones here. Uh
obviously we expect that to come down as
competition increases but we think and
listen to this. We think there is a
decent possibility that AI lab margins
and hyperscaler operating income margins
are higher than we illustrate. So
they're trying to brand this as, oh,
we're actually being conservative.
We think that the profit could actually
be higher for these companies. Okay,
that's really interesting. But listen to
the following line. But we would assume
that these margins come down a bit over
time as competition increases at the
frontier and compute scarcity eases.
These companies are so afraid to
acknowledge the deflation that's coming
to compute and to tokens because if
Barclays came out here and said, "Oh
yeah, you know, compute costs are going
to plummet and the open the the
hyperscalers are going to go BK." You
think you think Google and SpaceX when
they go to fund raise money is going to
call up Barclays and go, "Hey, Barclays,
we want to get a loan from you." No,
man. They're going to go get a loan from
Adam Jonas.
>> $5,000 SpaceX price target.
[laughter]
Come on, man. It's all rigged. So,
this like this hedging they're doing
here is insane.
We think we would assume these margins
come down a bit over time. Come on,
dude. The margins are going to plummet
when the compute scarcity goes away.
When the memory scarcity goes away, they
are going to plummet in margin.
Anyway,
it frustrates me because I I read these
things and then it just like I want to
scream. That's maybe that's why we have
such a soundrated room. [laughter] and
just like was sealed in a bunker because
so we could scream in here at the crap
that we read sometimes. Juicy
hyperscaler profits projected here. Uh
these are the hyperscalers. They argue
that out of the lab revenue mix 100%.
The uh hyperscalers will be able to
bring about 11.8% of all of that to
profit about 35% directly to their
revenue. So you can see the circularity
there where the money is literally going
from lab to hyperscaler which then of
course goes into compute which gets
recycled to Nvidia and then Nvidia
recycles that into investments into
companies that they choose to win which
then gets recycled back into the top as
uh as you know inference spend.
[laughter]
It's a very interesting economy we've
got right now. Subscription products
like claude code or codecs generally
have lower inference margins than API.
So now this I find very interesting
because ultimately subscription products
will be the true value generators. Uh
that's my expectation. Subscription
products or software that actually
provides real value for corporations.
That's going to be where the real money
is in artificial intelligence in the
long term. So companies that are able to
combine deterministic solutions with
software, artificial intelligence, uh
generative AI, whatever, they're going
to really make money. I call those the
value enablers. So you've got
infrastructure at the top, which creates
tokens. Both one and two commoditize.
Value enablers, those are your software
companies, you know, Palunteer,
whatever, SAP, UiPath, uh whatever. And
then some of them might get disrupted
away. Those are the where the real money
is. Now in fairness anthropic in my
opinion if it if it really wants to have
staying power it needs to get into the
value enabler side and to some extent
they are with claude code or open AI's
codeex those are value enabler softwares
the underlying tokens can commoditize
but that software like claude code might
have real staying power that's the
business you want to underwrite if you
want to buy the anthropic IPO you should
underwrite them solely from a software
value enabler point of view. That's the
only thesis of value these companies
have in my opinion. Not the token
factory, not the infrastructure. It's
what they could do for value. And they
bluntly tell you that portion of the
business is going to have a lower margin
than API. And API is going to get
crushed by um either in-house API that
you could run. Well, it's not really API
then. uh uh you know in-house compute
that you could run or Chinese openweight
models that you could also run in-house
or you get really cheap compute again
for Fable you're paying 50 bucks per
million output tokens for a Quen from
Alibaba you're paying 41
for some of the GPT models or Gros
you're paying1 to $3 per million output
tokens so why am I going to pay $3 if I
could pay 41 cents and why the H double
hockey sticks I'm going to pay $50 if I
could pay 41.
This is almost tokens are almost perfect
competition.
They are almost one for one replaceable
commodities.
Almost.
Uh okay. So over time inference profits
should eventually surpass training
costs. Hopefully that's their goal. But
see here, they acknowledge
that training is really expensive
[laughter]
and should drive higher profit margins.
So they really have to mislead you up
front and then later they're like,
"Yeah, you know, over time the training
will become less important." Well, as
soon as the training becomes less
important, the Chinese labs win anyway.
Hyperscalers likely start to lose market
share of AI lab training and inference
starting in 2028 when the backs stopped
AI infrastructure projects come online
and become the first option for AI labs.
Okay, so
let's think about this for a moment.
What they're really saying here is well
let's read the the next line here. uh we
generally see Amazon Web Services,
Microsoft Azure and Google Cloud
controlling a similar mix of AI lab
compute spend in the next 2 years before
this shift to backs stopped
infrastructure kicks in aka
Amazon, Microsoft and Google have
pricing power now for their labs but
after that that pricing power moat might
go away. So I wrote that in yellow here.
I wrote basically Microsoft Meta, Amazon
have a good moat for the next two years.
Note, they did not mention Meta. If Meta
jumps in and turns their compute online,
they'd be a possible unexpected entrance
benefiting Meta and obviously taking
some of the market share from AWS,
Microsoft, Google. Uh, and just in like
full disclaimer here because for just
like an avoidance of doubt of of like
exposure, I don't have any exposure to
Anthropic. I don't have any like venture
capital exposure to anthropic or OpenAI.
Um, I do have a little bit of exposure
to Microsoft and Meta, both of those. uh
and not to Google and Amazon. So, I
don't think I'm biasing in any direction
here, but but I always just I think it's
when in doubt, shout it out. [laughter]
Oh, to when in doubt, shout it out. Did
you know we had to extend the JPAL
coupon code? Did do you know why?
Because of the software, bro. Uh,
Teachable like screwed us. Literally the
night of our coupon code expiration, the
software, the payment rail failed and
then it took them like till the next
day. They're like, "Hey, sorry. We fixed
your problem." And we got like a ton of
emails. I just printed five of them, but
we got a ton of emails from people like,
"I WAS TRYING TO BUY and I couldn't use
the coupon code." So, we did extend the
coupon code Jhole to Friday. I feel bad
about that and that's why I printed that
because I don't want people to feel
like, "Oh, Kevin's changing his mind."
you know, extended the coupon and I'm
like, I feel bad for all the people that
wanted to sign up and then ended up
getting screwed literally on coupon code
expiration night. I'm like, man, that is
a ripoff.
So, uh, so shout out to these folks.
Christian, Charles, thanks. Thanks for
being in my email photos here. But, uh,
come on, man. Uh, anyway, so where were
we? So, we were right here on train.
Okay. So, so Meta entering, by the way,
could also be a big catalyst for MetaT.
I'm a big believer of that. Uh I think
that Meta has planted the seeds that
they are willing like they've basically
sent out this little balloon. Let me
explain that a little bit more clearly
because that might not be critically
clear. So I think based on the
conference calls that uh Mark Zuckerberg
has had with employees and also the
commentary that he's had on uh earnings
calls, I think that Mark Zuckerberg
basically suggested, hey, if somebody
pays us enough, we'll rent them compute.
And so what he's really done is he's
taken this shell of meta and said our
compute, it's our money, they're our
chips. And he kind of just like a couple
months ago I was like, you know, I'm
going to I'm just going to raise a
little balloon here and I'm going to
say, hey, you know what? For sale and
I'm just going to kind of like let it
hang out over there. And as somebody
bites on this, basically fishing J hook,
uh, not to be confused with J-Hold the
coupon code. Somebody bites on this, I
think he's going to take it. And that
might be pretty unexpected for how the
market is valuing a meta right now.
That's my opin again. May maybe I'm
biased. I mean I'm not trying to show
Microsoft you got exposure to that one
too. Uh I think that's that's just an
honest potential based on the seeds that
have been planted here. But anyway,
so on training inference profits, you
should probably surpass training. Okay,
so I'm quoting what they wrote there.
And then of course that's the whole play
by investing in them post IPO. My belief
is margin gets squeezed too much by open
weights. They then have to decide, do we
slow training, slow compute acquisition
and just focus on software? To me, you
should want to underwrite, this is what
I've already said, you should want to
underwrite them as a software play. If
they pencil as a software play alone,
great. I'm not giving much value to them
selling inference tokens. I should also
add to that, I'm not giving them much
value for, you know, basically being a
lab either because I think those things
will all be commodities. That said, I'm
not here saying anthropic or open will
be bad investments. I think they need to
transition from just being a frontier
lab to being a great software play. And
I think they know that. You know, Sam
Alman had an interview where where he's
like, "Oh, you know, we're we're
surprised with how used to people are
using the same software and over and
over again, they have this tendency to
just do more of the same thing." And
that's actually made it harder to break
into the software space. Sam Alman said
this in an interview and it was a great
point on software uh and in my opinion a
fair acknowledgment of how challenging
it really is to acquire that sort of
customer base. Uh so that to me is is
very interesting. Uh but uh hey, you
know, uh that's a that's a solid I think
overview uh from the Barclay's piece on
the labs, but it actually corresponds
really well to the Wells Fargo argument
that, you know, markets are a little
nervous about the spend. So I put this
note in the Meet Kevin app, which you
could download for free. You just go
into the Apple or Android app store,
type in Meet Kevin, and you can use the
Meet Kevin app. I put this note in the
Meet Kevin app, totally for free. You
could see it. uh and it's under the data
tab, which is one of the first tabs you
see there. And it's uh it's the
following note. This is what our desktop
web app looks like. Keep in mind, you
could also use the web app. I know this
is a little confusing. I should honestly
have like a piece of paper outlined on
this, but you got to sign up for the
mobile app first. Log in, make a
username or whatever. If you want the
desktop app after that, which we just
released like I don't know, six weeks
ago or whatever, maybe even less than
that, use the same login info and go to
app.mec.com.
Then you can log in and then you could
get, you know, all this stuff on on
desktop, which I think is very useful.
But anyway, here you go. How big does AI
have to get? Somebody Tom from MySpace
says, so invest in house. You know,
Houseack, now known as Reinvest, owns
all this stuff. House hack uh aka
Reinvest uh owns the Meet Kevin app, the
Alpha membership, the Homes AI. Uh every
Jhole coupon code that somebody, you
know, uses goes right into the top line
over at Reinvest. Uh and then we can
reinvest that into real estate, which is
very, very exciting. Anyway, how big
does AI have to get? We estimate the
required gross output from AI cloud plus
LLM margin is 1.4 trillion by 2028 to
justify the current AI capex plans X
meta. It equates to 2.6% of gross US
output 50% of information gross output
and 2.2% of consensus 2028 or sorry 2.2x
tox consensus 2028 estimated revenue for
the S&P 500 software XCloud cloud
compute like storage assuming another $1
trillion of AI capex X meta in 2028 AI
demand will have to grow 2.2 two
trillion by 2029. These are just these
sort of OG fears [music] that there's
too much investment and not enough
revenue coming out of AI productivity.
Uh so, you know, that's another reason
why this anthropic moment is going to be
so important because people are going to
want to see like how much money are they
actually making versus not, right?
That's what's critical here. Uh and so
we'll see. It's going to be very very
interesting. Why not advertise these
things that you told us here? I feel
like nobody else knows about this.
>> We'll we'll try a little advertising and
see how it goes.
>> Congratulations, man. You have done so
much. People love you. People look up to
you.
>> Kevin Praath there, financial analyst
and YouTuber. Meet Kevin. Always great
to get your take.